so I've done a bunch of videos on
atheism lately and I've noticed that
there is a real trend in the media but
also in a lot of left-wing circles and
it often comes from the right to sort of
this this new hatred of atheists which I
am completely fascinated by and I really
really don't understand what I'm seeing
is they're calling them the new atheists
or the neo atheists and it's this new
group and that you know included in that
group I guess they include guys like
Richard Dawkins and sam Harris and
people seem to think that they're
somehow like political atheists and that
they're trying to push I think their
atheism through political means even
though I don't really see them doing
that I see them having a lot of
philosophical debates about you know how
politics should go or usually it's about
the self and then then how that
translates into politics but anyway I've
noticed a lot of hate on the on the far
left and from the far right on atheist
and I think it is such a bad thing
that's happening here because atheists I
want you to think for a second about the
atheists that you know either were the
ones that you know in your personal life
are the ones that you're seeing on TV or
on the internet or whatever is is this
bad stuff that's happening in the world
the radicalism the militarization the
the stealing of privacy all of that
stuff all the bad stuff that's going on
is it coming from
atheists I don't think so I don't think
it is and I think that they're just sort
of a new group to attack like it's
really easy to attack them I guess
they're not that well organized you know
they say that something like 20% I think
of Americans are atheists yet for some
reason they're not you know joined
together to form some sort of political
party I mean imagine that think about
the way politics works every little
group every really just group every
ethnic group every every every group has
lobbyists they band together and they
say oh well this many Hispanics voted
this way and this many black people
voted this way etc etc but imagine if
atheists came together what they could
do using science and rationality and
things that I think most of us actually
believe in when we remove the periphery
so don't listen to the far-right and
don't listen to the far left when they
tell you that the new atheists or the
neo atheists are the problem I don't
think atheists are causing any of the
prowl
and I'm pretty sure you don't think that
either because basing your thoughts on I
don't know and rationalization is
usually pretty good and I said I mean
they're all perfect nobody's all perfect
but I don't really think that atheists
are the problem